[Musique]
il y aura de quoi se régaler pour cette
deuxième partie de saison
pour les gourmands culturel impossible
d'échapper à la troisième édition des
rencontres in cité du théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
ils vous invitent à table du 16 au 23
mars pour qu'on se met à table et qu'on
mange pas ainsi comme dans certaines
cultures
d'où viennent certaines habitudes
alimentaires qu'est ce qu'on trouve dans
nos aliments voilà une approche
anthropologique sociologique culinaire
ludique gustatives aussi puisqu'on va
avoir certains spectacles au cours
desquelles on pourra sanctionner le
sentir boire manger
le 1er février le théâtre espace coluche
de plaisir accueille celle à la
chanteuse de variétés revient sur scène
avec le groupe astag pour un concert
rock
belle étoile
ce même mois le 15 403 présentent leur
nouvel album un concert avec une
nouvelle formation scénique pour écouter
notamment kippen d'antiques osaka et mon
petit poney
[Musique]
l'humour a aussi sa place de christelle
chollet à montigny le bretonneux à
christophe alévêque un mot repas en
passant par françois xavier demaison aux
prises mind en cours
vous pourrez rire à gorge déployée j'ai
dépensé beaucoup d'argent en payant très
cher une avocate pour qu'elle dise du
mal de mon ex femme ma mère le faisait
très bien et gratuitement pour les plus
jeunes la culture est aussi au rendez
vous le public pourra faire des
enfantillages en famille nier mais cale
de berre en mai à la ferme du mas n'est
pas souvent qu'on ne challenge permet
super convoi
super pour ims